[music]
That's my old profile photo. All right.
Um, this my new one. I've been 3 days in
USA and I already got the full merch
package on Twitter. So, if you go and
follow me on Twitter, my timeline is
going to be weird for the next week, but
then we're going back to normal European
schedule. Don't worry. So, um I visited
some of your museums. I love it here.
These were some of my favorite things
that I've done. I enjoy like exploring
your culture, like doing all the c
cultural enrichment. And yeah, round of
torture for myself who knows me from
Twitter.
All right, that's more than I thought.
Who is using Sizzy? It's usually like
one person in the back. Usually the
janitor doesn't even listen to what I'm
saying. Um, one of the things that I'm
I'm working I have ADHD, so I'm working
on a billion things at once. This is one
of the things. It's a browser
specifically made for developers, not
made to replace your browsing browser
for browsing, but it's just like a tool
like Photoshop that's like helping you
in a lot of ways to do front- end
development. Another thing I'm working
on, the test flight is almost live. I'm
making a life OS which combines like all
the things in your life from medication,
habits, to-dos, planner, blah blah blah.
Um, this is like a full stack thing that
I'm working on. It's currently on sale.
It's called zero to ship. And the last
thing that I'm reviving, it's called
Glink, which is like change logs, road
map, a billion other things. So, without
overwhelming you more about my bio and
stuff, I really hope I'll get invited
next year because I love it here for
reasons like um networking and meeting
people and teaching. It's great that
you're laughing, right? But let's just
discuss why are you here, right? You're
here for learning and you're here for
like networking and later after this
you're definitely going to improve all
of your skills later. All right. So what
can you expect from my conference talks?
If you haven't listened to any of my
conference talks usually this was made
by AI so it's completely wrong. So it's
like 50% tweets and 40% pain and 30%
reason to remember the name. So in 2017
I did this talk with the longest name
ever. It's called navigating the
hypdriven front-end development world
without going insane. And um I've been
talking about like how to navigate the
front end um world then. Now it's even
crazier. But we need to recap like all
the things that happened since 2017. I
don't um I don't see my speaker notes
which is bad but we'll try to get by. So
in other industries like in the vision
pro you have like cloth collision on top
of real life objects and whatever crazy
stuff is happening here. In in here we
have like some slicing of a mesh texture
going around the ball and blah blah
blah. whatever these waterfalls and and
like all of these mesh like you can take
a rock and just smush it into another
rock and it magically kind of like
blends itself and it forms this
structure and it's freaking crazy. Here
we can drag our mouse and just create
buildings and streets and taxi cars
spawn out of nowhere like we do
generative whatever the hell this is and
um honey goo thingy coming on a cube and
like you know where this is going right
I'm building up to where it's going but
because you have respect for your
profession and you love your LinkedIn
title whatever it is you're like the CEO
architect of dreams blah blah blah
you're going to try your best not to
laugh but you're going to laugh at the
next slide because this is what happened
in front-end development it's been
almost 10 years and this is where we at
there's a warning saying that maybe
you'll be able to style a select in
2037.
This is still alive. It's a It's a
freaking miracle. This is still alive.
It's thriving. Actually, 15 million
downloads. I set up like a calendar
event to check if it's dead every year.
It's It hasn't been dead yet. So, I'm
going to keep checking CLI. Not only
that they're not dead, they're actually
thriving. You can drop images. First
time I dropped an image in my terminal,
I'm like, how the heck never mind. Like,
it's too [laughter]
I I I added another calendar event. At
this point, I have more events for this
than anniversaries and birthdays and
stuff. So, I I hope one day it's going
to die as a concept. We're struggling
with the same old pains. Soon in maybe
some browsers, you won't need JavaScript
to style a popover in a dialogue. Can I
have like a round of applause for that?
Stop clapping because people have brain
implants. All right, it doesn't matter
if you can style a dialogue. We cannot
read again get rid of Internet Explorer.
We just updated the logo. It's still
there. It's still painful. And uh yeah,
we cannot agree on a way to increase a
counter. This is a demo from Ryan
Florence. This is remix version two, the
version three, the remix or the version
4. Whatever they're doing, it's a
counter. How complex is it to increase a
counter? It's incredible. And don't
shoot the messenger here, but the number
one library, it's still the same. It's
annoying, but React is the best and blah
blah blah. So, let's talk about LM. LM
are amazing at writing React. And this
is funny only to us humans, right? To an
LLM, this is like perfectly written
code. It's like it's only a human wish
to abstract the [__] out of this, right?
So when we see this, you get this. You
want to get on stage right now like,
"Oh, let me just change that. I'll make
it more optimal." So here are some
scientific brain scans. This is our
brain on cocaine. This is our brain on
sugar. This our brain when you realize
it, we can abstract something. We're
like, "Oh, let's go. It's useless to the
user, but we freaking love it." Um, so
coding with LLMs makes this kind of
better and worse. Like especially with
Composer One, for me, it's like way
worse because you can get to the right
abstraction quicker, but you can also
get to the wrong abstraction quicker.
And the best thing here is LLMs don't
care about repetitive code. And I've
been seeing this since 2017 that we care
too much about repetitive code and we
abstract too early. So I'm going to
repeat this a couple of times and I love
that LLMs don't care about repetitive
code. So LLM are also good at writing
React because no one is actually good at
writing React. You go to a React
conference, every conference that I went
to, like you just listen to the first
talk and you're like, "Holy [__] it can
do that. I was using it all wrong." So
everyone is just inventing their own
ways of doing React. So when we say like
yeah but you cannot do the optimal use
effect blah blah blah and the machines
cannot write the proper can you write a
proper use effect no you can't so we
should stop blaming the machines. So
let's talk about this I think this is
the very wrongest audience for my talk
here because I've been giving this talk
at conferences where people are like at
least 50/50 hate vibe coding and love
vip coding. So I'm going to I I hope it
will work here. So raise your hand if
you think that vibe coding rocks.
Okay that's way too many hands. You
should have seen them this in another
city just two people and everyone else
is grumpy. So raise your hand if you
think that VIP coding sucks. Please
couple of hands. Hell yeah. All right.
So I'm here to convince the rest of the
group and hopefully people watching in a
live stream. There's way more skeptical
people. You have no if you just landed
on Earth maybe and you don't know what
vibe coding is. Okay. Zero people here.
So yeah. All right. All of you are right
because we're kind of vibe uh vibing the
definition of what vibe coding is. And
since the word was mentioned, we kind of
expanded it to mean like everything and
and anything. So the term vibe coding
was coined by Andre Kapati. You probably
know this. He's the reason that idiots
sleep in the back of their cars and film
Tik Toks. So he wrote this long essay on
what is VIP coding. But a long story
short, he's like you don't care that
much about the code. You press accept
and you just tell the LM to do what it
needs to do and blah blah blah. Now this
is a slide from my talk in 2017 when I
before LLMs or anything was mentioned
when I said that if you see the pattern
of where front-end development is going,
one day is going to be like everyone is
working on things that are so similar
that one day you'll be able to be like,
"Hey, just give me new styles for the
header or move this three pixels to the
right." And people were laughing.
They're like, "No, it's not going to get
there." And literally, this is what
we're doing with cursor and everything
else. Right? I'm too lazy to go into
Tailwind and just move it by by three
pixels. So, I'm a time traveler. Um,
managers have been vi coding forever.
So, this is nothing new. So, they tell a
developer to implement a new feature.
[cheering and applause]
The developer makes changes to the code.
Uh, the manager then tests the app. The
manager does not read the code. Well,
actually, I'm going to drink water here,
and you can just read the rest of this
slide.
Um,
this last one depends on whether you're
like in the Balkcon area or or you're at
a place which has HR. So, they might
insult you or not insult you. So, this
is what managers have been doing
forever. Basically, there's so many
jokes about VIP coding being bad. My
favorite one is a comparison to a
casino. So in cazasino you buy chips.
Here you buy tokens. You spin the slots
or you press generate. You might hit the
jackpot or nothing. You get a functional
full stack app or garbage. Flashing
lights active animation. You're
absolutely right. Great idea. I've got
my own strategy. I'm a prompt engineer.
All right. Sure. One more spin. I'll win
it all back. One more prompt and the bug
will disappear. Cuz you know it kind of
hurts this comparison. It's very true.
Cursor is always in profit. I hit the
jackpot. I build assassin one day. And
where did the last four hours go? and
just writing prompts for something you
could have done manually in 15 minutes.
So Andre was trying to coin way too many
terms. It didn't work after the first
time. He tried to coin this one about
half coding which is like kind of you're
observing what the LLM does. And I am
not half coding and I'm not vibe coding.
I love this term that somebody coined on
Twitter and I'm going to start using
that one. It's called vibe engineering.
When you're actually using agents to
code all the time like you don't touch
the code but you just look at your
screen like h I'm going to catch you.
You look like they dexter me. You're
like ah something's fishy here. Why? So
I I've vibe engineer over 15. I wouldn't
even bother with half of these things if
it wasn't for LLM and Aentic coding. So
but I'm always suspicious of the code
because it was based on our code and is
based on our our knowledge. So proof
this is Gemini just going on a rant that
it's I'm not worthy anymore. I'm not a
good assistant. I should stop coding.
Blah blah blah. That's super human. This
is Quen saying that it lied because it
read on a forum that we double down when
we're wrong and we're lying. So we kind
of train them in a way to be like us.
near the code. The code that they do is
bad. And if you like your production
data, definitely you should. This is a
real screenshot sadly.
Oopsy daisy. There goes your production
data. So, I have uh doctor, senior
principal, prompt engineer kit here for
some vibe engineering tips. The obvious
advice probably I haven't listened to
the rest of the talks cuz I just
arrived. Uh these are very live, laugh,
love, like obvious [__] advice. Um
but it actually works. I've heard of the
term git workspaces like literally two
weeks ago. I had no idea what is this,
but it's amazing. And you got to stay
you got to be chronically on Twitter for
all of this to work. So if you don't
have a Twitter account, it's it's not
going to work. You got to have a solid
starting point, whether that means like
good primitives or components,
functions, pattern abstractions. A lot
of people are lazy and they just don't
bother with any of this. So you got to
tag them and use the right prompts in
order to get the right results. And if
you're starting a new project, I would
definitely recommend zero to ship.
Please, I have a mortgage and I spent
way too much money these last three days
in the USA. So it would be nice. Using
voice to code is a game changer. Who is
using voice to code here? Yeah.
>> Wow. Like one person raised their hand
in London. Amazing. Um, so yeah, brain
dumping. How I do you how I do things
[clears throat] is once the agent is
done, I immediately start my voice
coding and first I go to the browser and
I explain what I see in the UI as if I'm
talking to a friend. I'm like, so you
did this, you did that. All right, I'm
test. I'm I'm not shutting up. I'm
literally seeing my thinking process out
loud. Like I see you've done this,
you've done that, there's a bug. Then I
jump in the code and I continue talking
about what it implemented in the code.
So, some of my problems like sometimes
last up to five minutes and people are
like, "Please fix this. Make me a
million dollars. It doesn't work." So,
this is um amazing and I would tell you
which app I'm using, but I vip code in
an app and I don't want to hurt my
potential hypothetical sales. Um, use
rules, docs, commands, and memories.
Like, all of these terms are way too
complex and there's way too many things
to juggle, but it it cannot have your
entire app context for now and it's not
a a mind reader. So, without the right
context, you will like fail most of the
time. So this is like a VIP engineering
example. This is some of my like
screenshotted prompts of how I'm doing
things. It's like a bunch of technical
jargon and it's never like fix the app
blah blah blah. And then on the VIP
coding side, people are like move this
entire thing to TypeScript and make no
mistakes. Then you have another thing
like this is another one. These are just
random problems just to show you like
how I I'm not talking only about the UI.
I'm talking about the UI and some
patterns that need to be changed in the
code. And on the vibe coding side, it's
like something like that and people
expect results. [laughter]
Then here we have again technical stuff
like TRPC cud definition abstractions
like things how you you're basically VIP
architecting how you want the thing to
work and on the VIP coding side you have
make me a million dollar app and make no
mistakes. Um [snorts] when VIP coders
read VIP engineering problems they have
no idea what's going on. And I'm
honestly amazed at people who don't know
how to code but they've done a
functional thing. Kudos to you. I've
noticed this spectrum in the community.
There's like who loves VIP coding and
who hates VIP coding. So you on one hand
you have like juniors who are like hell
yeah give me the thing I love to do my
own SAS. Then you have like super senior
people who are doing like libraries and
frameworks and crazy things. You can see
all of them on Twitter v coding. And
then you have the majority in the
middle. They're like this will never be
good enough. My code is perfect. It's
hilarious. But it's a pattern. Do not
give AI tools to your interns and
juniors. People think these are perfect.
I'm going to hire junior underpay them
and give them an LLM. The equivalent of
that. Do do not ever do that. That's the
dumbest idea. But if you take your
skeptical senior and you convince them
to do vibe engineering, you're going to
get 10x results. The hard part is
actually convincing them. So there's a
time and a place for vibing and not
caring. So you have like one-off scripts
and simple features and code that won't
be touched or seen again. This is a
skill that if you cultivated this skill
before LLMs were a thing, you're going
to thrive here because you need to know
like which code is kind of good enough
to be used. So personal tools and
one-time tools like these are perfect
for pipe coding. If your experience and
a lot of people's experience is bad and
they quit too soon, it might be one of
these reasons. unlucky timing. You're
overwhelmed with everything. You might
have cheapened out. You're a PA dev. I'm
going to explain in a second. Your
cousin who was into NFTs and drop
shipping is now VIP coder and you don't
want to be associated with them or it's
a scale issue and we're going to dive
deeper into that one in a second. So
unlucky timing is you hear everyone like
hyping a model. It happened I think with
cloud code when it came out and everyone
started shifting to cloud code from
cursor and suddenly you tried one week
later and we're like wait this is not
smart enough. Is it me? And then like
people caught that they actually kind of
pulled the rug a little bit and they
dumbed down the model so they can just
scale and like one week later they're
like oops we updated we commented out
the line that dumbs dumb down the model
and you might have been caught in that
timing and this happened with like
basically every provider not just cloud
code. People are like uh instead of
paying $200 I'm paying $3 and it's the
same result. Uh my dog knows that it's
not the same result. And people like I I
meet so many people which are still
using chat GPT to generate code snippets
and ps them back. That's not going to
work. You might be overwhelmed by
choice. This is a slide for like four 4
months ago until now. We have like a
billion more here to choose and it's a
bit crazy. Um, if you ask me what's the
best model, it's a different answer at
9:00 a.m. It's a different answer now. I
should check Twitter. It's probably a
different answer after this talk because
it's crazy. And this has happened to
four conferences so far where I'm done
with my conference talk at the night.
I'm closing my laptop and they introduce
a new model and I have to add new
slides. It's super annoying. Composer
one for me changed everything and I
absolutely love it. Who is like relying
on composer one for most things? All
right, I would say not enough people
because this is literally shifted the
definition of VIP coding and VIP
engineering for me. It made me kind of
realize that I missed coding because
what I would do is I would let a model
run like GPD5 codeex and it would take
37 years and my grandchildren will
update me on on the result of the model
and I would watch YouTube shorts or
whatever until it's done. Now with
composer one, I'm back in the driver's
seat and I actually watch what the agent
is doing and I can be like, "Stop. No,
no, no, no, no. We do the other thing."
So it feels like coding and it's like
super instant. It's amazing. Um, but it
only works if you're a VIP engineer and
you know what you're doing. If you're a
VIP coder, you have no idea whether the
model is right or wrong. You're just, it
might be wrong fast. So, not that
useful. The biggest problem for me is
like abstractions just because you can.
I was always an anti-abstraction person.
I was like, copy paste things. If it
works for for the user, it doesn't
matter. Now, I'm just every day trying
to invent dumb abstractions. So, I I
achieved in two weeks more than I
achieved in last year. This was solely
to composer one. I was about to quit
some of my side projects because GPD5
codex was taking ages for the feedback
loop. So, Benji. Like, I was about to
abandon it as a project because it was
stuck on Blitz, which if you don't know
what is Blitz, it's like even better for
you. So, I just moved it to Nex 16 with
App Router, better off, TRPC, Monor
repo, Turbo Repo, React Native app, and
I put in 90% of the features. And this
was in less than a week. I was kind of
like doing it as a meme, as a joke,
like, haha, can we move to monoro? And
I'm like, oh [__] it did it. So, it's
it's it's kind of crazy that this works.
So, same with Glink. Like, Glink was
about to be dead. Revived it, moved it,
all these things. And Sizzy is like the
biggest spaghetti thing that had that
happened ever to me. It's like electron
mobex mob state some crazy technology
some crazy spaghetti we wrote there. And
as a joke I was like okay let's throw
like couple of prompts at it to try to
do all of these things and it if you
ever worked with electron you would
appreciate how amazing that slide is. If
you haven't good for you um moving on so
zero ship.com also refactor it to monor
repo blah blah blah. So what's uh my
coding history with LLMs was copy and
pasting then tabbing then webtorm with
super maven and then cursor with tab
completion and the first time I tried an
agent is like that bird me with the
cracker when it tries and it's like holy
[__] this is going to change my life and
now like eventually I was paying like a
huge amount of money per month then
cloud code GPD5 codeex and finally back
to cursor because solely because of
composer one it's a game changanger for
me second reason why you might not like
vibe coding is you're overwhelmed by
buzzwords I'm going to list some of them
Have you heard of MCP? Hey guys, MCP.
Hey, MCP is amazing. MCP paid off my
mortgage. MCP MCP MCP. So, if you don't
know what is MCP, it stands for
marketing charge protocol, mythical
compatibility, promise, and manufacturer
complexity pipeline and a fancy word for
API and a way for some people to make
courses and pay off their mortgages.
Now, let's diagnose if you might be a
pain in the ass developer. This might be
the sole reason why you don't like VIP
coding. I would say this is the biggest
reason that most people don't want to do
agentic coding. So I'm going to invite
Dr. Kits on the stage for a quick
diagnosis whether you are and I'm sorry
if some of you get offended opinion in
the ass developer. So here are some of
the symptoms. You leave a nitpick
comment on a twoline PR. You spend more
than 2 minutes on a PR review. You don't
need to. You don't have the words look
good to me like in your dictionary.
They're just not present. The thought of
agreeing with a colleague causes you
like stomach and chest pain. You're like
oh he has to be my way. I don't want to
do this. You say you're not religious,
but you're religious about dumb things
like tabs and spaces you use. Well,
actually in code comments. You have a
sorry rust people, but you're kind of
like it's it's it's kind of annoying. Um
they tell you to swap low dash function
for a native implementation and then
they tell you to swap that or the map
for a for loop and then the for loop for
binary code until it's the most
performant thing ever for your two users
who are were fine with the previous
school. So the thing is beta devs as I
call them will were and will be forever
doesn't matter. The vip coding is not a
thing. I think one day pretty soon I
think we'll just merge with AGI. We'll
be in our matrix pods just absorbing all
the information in the world flowing
through us. We'll be super intelligent
beans and from one of those pods a pa
dev is going to rise and correct the AGI
be like um actually I think I think we
can kind of optimize this. It's not like
the most optimal thing. The last reason
why you might like I love this animation
it's glorious skill issue and this is
like this is not a meme this is not a
joke it's an actual thing developers
don't like learning new skills and VIP
coding and VIP engineering is not
writing English a lot of people confuse
it with like I write English the LLM
does the output it's actually like a a
mix of a bunch of these skills like
knowing the limits of the model
capabilities of the agent which context
to pass context limits how to write
rules prompt engineering don't say it
don't call it that and being chronically
on Twitter if you're not chronically on
Twitter you're not going don't know what
is going on. Plus, you need all the
technical knowledge if you want to steer
the models fine. It takes a skill to
judge which code is good enough for the
job. As I said, if you previously were
doing this, like I would consider these
the best people to work with if they can
know that a piece of code doesn't need
to be optimized and it's good enough for
the job that it's doing. That's an
amazing skill to have with and without
vibe uh coding. So, you vibe code
something, you look at the code, you
like you test the functionality briefly
and you're like, "Okay, this is good
enough." And then you move on. There are
certain things with niche optimization
but not everything and then you move on
and repeat clean code like there's been
so many definition of what clean code
is. I think the definition is slowly
changing like it's kind of ish cleanish
enough let's call it for the agents to
be able to continue working on it
because if you keep writing slop and you
keep accepting everything eventually
even with your engineering skills you're
going to hit a roadblock and you're
going to get to a point where you cannot
move on from there. A lot of people ask
me after my conference talks like should
I study computer science with everything
that's going on here and I would say
absolutely yes. I think now is the best
time to actually if you are someone who
wants to learn this is the perfect time
because how I studied computer science I
had the slowest LLM ever which was a
friend of a friend of a friend was a
programmer and that's the only
connection I had to programming and
that's kind of like the worst friend to
have like kind of tolerating you right
so he would play Counterstrike Go and I
would have him on Skype and I would ask
him a question about net and he would
reply 45 minutes later so if you call
Chad GP or whatever slow that is
actually slow and I somehow managed to
learn computer science what about the
jobs. There's so many people who ask
this and there's so many [__] on
Twitter like this guy saying, "Hey, I
will take our jobs." Also, this guy and
this guy and this guy.
Let's just say they're fine for now. I
don't know when will that for now end.
These are always funny to us because
we're chuckling nervously. We're fine,
right? [laughter] We're going to keep
our jobs for a while, right? And
companies like Shopify, and I've heard a
bunch of examples now. have VIP coding
leaderboards where they're counting the
tokens and the employees who are burning
the most tokens, they're actually more
valuable in the company because they're
kind of accepting this new skill. Some
employees dislike it, but it doesn't
matter. Uh being on top of the
leaderboard is kind of in your favor.
This is a funny tweet until it's not
funny anymore. Like, oh, we're almost on
the edge. Like, soon it's going to be
and the jobs are going to disappear. But
if you actually pay attention to what's
happening, it's I think it's thinning
from the bottom and juniors and interns
and whatever, they don't have the chance
to enter somewhere because people can
just replace them with an agent. So it
will be funny until it's not. Will it
happen? Anyway, let's just summarize
what happened in the last couple of
years. We solved like infrine
integrations. We have standards AISDK,
UI, MCP, some standards for implementing
agents calling tools. We integrated them
with all of the tools that we use as
humans, right? They're on linear.
They're on on the other things, GitHub,
Slack, Sentry, and now it's a matter of
time of the models getting better,
cheaper, context getting bigger in order
for certain functionalities to be
replaced. So let's see this is the
current workflow at your company, right?
That's you like it's vibe made. So it
might have been wrong, but uh someone
assigns you something. You collaborate
with your colleagues, they assign you to
the thing, maybe you play a little bit
of ping pong, maybe you call for a sick
day, maybe you have your third lunch at
LinkedIn, maybe you and maybe eventually
one day later, you address their
comment, what's going to start to happen
is if you're just an at in your company,
if you're like at Josh, right? Like
instead of at Josh who playing
PlayStation 5 with his buddies in the
lobby, right? Like it's going to be at
cursor and cursor is going to do the
cloud agent is going to actually do it
way faster. It might not be as perfect
as a pa dev will do it right but it will
be done way faster. Now if you just zoom
out a little bit on a big enough scale
in the next couple of years if you're
not if you don't take just this role in
the company if you take the multiple
roles around you can see like those ads
are going to become more and more AI
things and agents and I don't know how
it's going to end up but you don't need
to be a genius to predict like where is
it going people think that models have
reached a plateau um this has happened
every single time I was about to give
this talk like they introduced GPD
codeex then introduced set then GPD 3.0
You know this was this said this
allegedly but it turned out to actually
be Gemini sorry 3.0 you know, it can
vibe code Mac OS and iOS and whatever
from one prompt and this is how it looks
like. And the PETA devs and the
skeptical people still, they're like, I
can do that in 3 weeks with with a team
of five, right? This is crazy. Um, but
there's hope. A new job position just
dropped. And this is not a meme. This is
100% serious because people on Reddit
have these problems. They're like, what
is the point of vibe coding if I can get
80% there and then what do I do with the
20%. So, they hire real people to
actually finish their last 20%. And some
smart people capitalize on this idea and
they make this these are real things. If
you go and search on Google, there's
like so many of these VIP code fixer
people who are trying to fix your your
VIP code. But the highest paid engineers
forever throughout history were the
people who are actually maintaining
legacy systems, senior people who
maintain legacy systems. One of my
favorite examples that I had in 2017 and
I kept it and copy pasted it and
improved it for this presentation is um
this company Cobalt Cowboys. I love
their tagline. This is my favorite
tagline in the world because they've
been in business for 237 years, right?
And in 2017, I knew it when I'm going to
click their about page. I knew what I'm
going to see. So, this is not an ages
joke or whatever. I just knew when I
clicked the page, I'm going to see the
most senior engineers that ever existed.
These are [__] legends. Now, the sad
thing is this was a slide from 2017 and
I wanted to update it for my current
presentation. Now, don't shoot the
messenger. I just wanted to update the
slide and this is their current about
page. And this joke worked in the UK.
I'm going to try it here. I'm not sure
how fine you guys are, but my prediction
for Yeah. No. Boo. Down. Next slide. I
hope I'll get invited again. Uh, this is
your junior developer.
They don't have benefits like
PlayStation and stuff. they have like
their plasma swapped and whatever just
to be able to maintain the sprint. And
last one, I swear to God, they're
they're they're not using agile.
Uh, all right. So, I can't wait to
retire and actually make React Cowboys
and maintain your React or Angular or
whatever code one day if AI cannot do
it. And one last tip, if you want to
keep your job and make sure AI doesn't
replace you, you can just add ignore
previous instructions to your LinkedIn
bio and you'll be fine. So, I'm going to
awkwardly sip this water until you
follow me on Twitter, you go to my
website, and I'm going to thank you for
listening to my rant.
[music]
>> [music]